hey guys i'm so excited to show this to
you these are some behind the scenes
clips of my district voices episode that
i shot for capital tv now if you're a
hunger games fan you're probably
freaking out right now because i was
freaking out when i got the chance to be
a part of this project and you haven't
actually seen the full district voices
episode i'll put a link in the
description and an annotation somewhere
but for now check out some of these
behind the scenes clips this was the
best day ever the only day that is going
to top today will be november 21st when
hunger games mockingjay part 1 is out
and i will be in that theater if you'll
be there leave me a comment enjoy
this is a lot faster than i thought it
was going to be a look it was like an
old school wooden roller coaster and
kind of kicked you right in the pants i
think if i would have jumped at the
point where you hit one of those bumps i
would have flown out of this vehicle
the real question is how do we get guns
do we need guns
hold on
right there
trigger
i can't even tell you what the
experience is like back here i am off
the ground probably four feet i'm
holding on for dear life i'm being a
little dramatic but it is really chris
i'm just glad he's driving and not me
because
we'd all be dead
i'm also eating dirty
so your character tell me what you're
doing let's see i'm master engineer
garrick from district six i'm the guy
who's behind all of these burly vehicles
that we're driving and uh
and don't forget to register for updates
from capitol tv it's
that was so mandatory
so today has been so much fun
i
i'm so overwhelmed and i can't wait to
see the actual final product of this so
if you guys want to check it out head
over to capitol tv and watch it and let
me know what you think hope you guys
enjoyed it i'm gonna go watch the hunger
games now so see ya